ah yes our entire education system today
was created because John D Rockefeller
needed more work s but it wasn't just
Rockefeller no loads of other Rich
American tycoons poured billions of
dollars into creating the modern day
education system we have today these are
the same wolfy dynasties behind Big Oil
big food big Pharma and they all wanted
to provide you with free conditioning I
mean education while they send their
kids to private schools as Rockefeller
once said I don't want a nation of
thinkers I want a nation of workers
these are the dark origins of our
education system and why you want to
stay dangerous